[Music]
welcome to episode 9 of our series of
essary and devops I'm Liz Fung Jones a
site reliability engineer at Google
where I teach Google cloud customers how
to build and operate reliable services
and I'm Seth a developer advocate at
Google focused on infrastructure and
operations so so I was hoping to help me
figure out why are things so chaotic
every time one of my services break so
what kind of chaos are you experiencing
too much data slow internet connections
corporate firewalls VPNs no that's not
actually what I mean I'm talking about
human chaos there's often both too much
communication and too little
communication at the same time everyone
wants to participate people are doing
random things that don't actually help
and people actually doing the work
aren't talking ah yes humans are
definitely an important part of the
incident management process it sounds
like you need to define very clear roles
and responsibilities for each of your
humans so that they know exactly what
they can do without getting in the way
I'd love to figure that out how do I get
started Seth first you'll need a process
for declaring incidents a dashboard for
viewing your current incidents and some
kind of database for who to contact when
an incident is in progress for different
kinds of incidents you'll also need to
set thresholds for when to declare an
incident and who can declare an incident
in your organization depending on the
scale of the incident you may also need
to bring in specialists from other parts
of the company in order to help resolve
the incident right I wouldn't
necessarily want to declare an incident
every single time and get paged but I
also wanted to feel supported in
declaring an incident if I need to bring
in other people then what
so I mentioned having someone to contact
the most critical role in the incident
response process is that of incident
commander or IC who is responsible for
making strategic decisions and
delegating additional roles to other
responders the other roles can also be
played by the incident commander but
tend to be delegated as the incident
grows in size or complexity the first
role that tends to be created is that of
the operations lead who is in charge of
gaining a detailed understanding of and
actually changing the state of the
system like running commands grabbing
log files etc I guess that only having
one person touching the system makes a
lot of sense but I'm not sure how that's
helpful to have the incident commander
isolated from the details don't they
need to know all those details so yes
and no I mean have you ever been driving
a car and
the dark in some foreign country on the
opposite side of the road and you're
trying to get where you need to go but
you can't a few times yes and it's super
difficult like I usually have to pull
over because if there's no one else in
the car with me I can't both look at the
map and figure out where am I going
where am i trying to go and then I Drive
safely at the same time I can't do that
all at once right so I think you just
answered your own question right if we
apply that same analogy to the
operations world it's hard to both plan
and perform to keep track of all of the
fine-grained details at the same time so
it's usually best to separate the two
roles to minimize the overhead of
context switching I see that makes a lot
of sense so the incident commander and
the operations lead under them but you
mentioned multiple roles what other
roles might an incident commander want
to delegate well have you ever had
external stakeholders like a support
team or executives who are bugging you
for updates during an outage all the
time or maybe if you're a public-facing
company perhaps you have a presence on
social media where your users are
constantly nagging you about the service
being down oh it's super distracting
especially if I'm the Operations lead
but isn't that just an instant
commander's job to do sometimes up to
the point that the incident commander
can no longer effectively do both the
planning and the communications work at
that point you'll want a communications
lead for communicating with other teams
or external stakeholders I see and what
if an infant grows so large that the
decision-making responsibility and the
planning and the logistical work becomes
too much work for one person to handle
then what so in that scenario you might
want to have a dedicated planning lead
having someone be in charge of writing
the plan maintaining the running notes
document and starting to draft the
post-mortem another common role is a
logistics lead who handles things like
securing rooms making sure that people
have food and water and other supplies
or you could get more creative depending
on the needs of your organization and
your business that makes a lot of sense
what can't they in some command or
delegate though it sounds like the
insane commander can delegate anything
so the incident commander can't delegate
overall decision-making responsibilities
the buck stops with them they have to
help their subordinates make decisions
tiebreak and the event that people can't
agree and coordinate adding new people
into the Incident Response hierarchy as
deemed appropriate and what if there
need to be multiple people working hands
on keyboard or most people need to be
doing the communications how does that
work I thought you said only one person
is in charge of operations so additional
subject matter expert
can join under the operations lead or
the overall communications lead might
want to designate someone to be on the
customer support team while another
person is handling social media for
external communications and what about
the role of managers and technical leads
do I automatically become the incident
commander just because I'm the most
senior person who turned up no not
unless you're specifically asked to the
person who declared the incident is
always the incident commander until they
designate a successor it's up to them to
decide what roles in which to place
people joining or even turn people away
if there are too many cooks in the
kitchen for long-running incidents the
incident commander may delegate a
successor in a more appropriate time
zone or geography as an incident evolves
in size or complexity some incident
commanders may want to give up the role
of IC and instead become the operations
lead great that should help clear up
some of the confusion and chaos from my
next incident thanks everyone for
watching and we hope you'll tune in next
time to learn what to do after an
incident to find out when we post your
upcoming episodes please like and
subscribe below
[Music]